There are many similarities and differences
between our little wing-whipping friends.
For starters, all can sting you.
That said, you may derive some solace in the
fact that when certain of them sting humans,
they die- not so when they sting many other
animals.
The barbed stingers on honey bees particularly
end up getting lodged in our soft flesh, ripping
out their backsides when they try and get
away after stinging you.
When they sting most animals, this doesn’t
happen.
Further, all three live in hives or combs.
These humble abodes are always in cooler and
sheltered areas, often within the shade of
trees.
Bees, wasps, and hornets all proliferate in
warm weather, their hives growing in the spring
and early summer.
By late summer, food becomes scarce and that’s
when they, especially wasps and hornets, start
finding their way to human food and your picnic.
While the colors are all pretty similar (brown/black,
yellow, with some white) on bees, wasps, and
hornets, the markings differ.
This is where the insects we all tend to lump
in the same category (flying, stinging, and
scary), begin to show their differences.
We start with the humble bee.
Bees are furry pollen collectors, who rarely
have any need to interact with humans.
As the expression “as busy as a bee” insinuates,
worker bees (usually the only type of bee
most people will see) spend their lives going
to and from the hive, acquiring nectar (and
pollen on their bodies) during their trips.
They play an integral part in the pollination
of various plants, and some of them provide
us with tasty honey.
bumblee2They feed the acquired nectar to their
young, developing the new generation of bees.
They also protect the queen bee, allowing
her to lay the eggs.
There are over 25,000 known bee species, but
the two most common types of bees are honeybees
and bumblebees.
Both produce wax, but only the honeybee produces
honey.
Another big difference between the two is
that the bumblebee is nearly double the size
of the honeybee.
Bumblebees are fat (at least in bee terms)
and hairy, their size relative to their wingspan
giving rise to the myth that science can’t
explain how they are able to fly.
Honeybees are more sleek.
They both are yellow with black stripes, though
the bumblebee often has a red/orange or white
tale.
Additionally, honeybees live in large colonies,
topping out at 25,000 bees.
Bumblebees tend build their nests underground
(though they have been found in walls), and
sometimes in tunnels constructed by other
animals.
Their colonies are much smaller than bumblebees,
only numbering into the hundreds.
waspWasps, unlike bees, are aggressive and
predators.
There are over 30,000 species of wasps and
they are distinguishable from bees by their
pointed lower abdomens and narrow “waist,”
a petiole, that separates the abdomen from
the thorax.
They also have little to no hair on their
bodies (as opposed to bees) and don’t play
much of a role in the pollination of plants.
Their legs are shiny, slender, and shaped
like cylinders.
All wasps hunt for their food and build nests
for shelter.
What exactly they prey on and how they build
their nests depends on the type of wasp.
There are two general types of wasps: social
and solitary.
Social wasps build colonies and start from
scratch every spring, never nesting in the
same spot twice.
They design their home sweet home out of chewed
up wood fibers and their own saliva.
The nests may hold up to five thousands wasps
and are typically found in protected spaces,
like attics, inside of walls, or under decks.
Social wasps eat many different types of things
(they are omnivorous) including fruits, plants,
human food, and other insects (flies, bee
larva, caterpillars, etc.)
Solitary wasps do not form colonies and live
under ground or in tubular mud nests.
There’s no caste system, as in the queen
cares for it’s own young.
The queen seeks out prey – flies, bee larva,
cicadas (there’s actually a species of wasp
known as “cicada killers”), and paralyzes
it with its sting.
They take the still-living insect back to
the nest and feed it to their larva.
It’s during the late summer when wasps begin
to get aggressive.
This is due to the fact that the worker wasps
job is done for the year and they’re, literally,
waiting to die.
After taking care of the queen and feeding
the new generation of worker wasps, the old
ones are now useless.
They become disoriented and begin to venture
away from the nest, in search of food and
something sweet.
As absurd as this sounds, these wasps have
nothing left to live for besides satisfying
their sweet tooth.
So, they become aggressive, bold, and persistent.
They land on a human hand that’s holding
an ice cream cone.
They dive into a can of soda.
They munch on a half-eaten apple.
In fact, in September of 2013, the British
Red Cross warned citizens that wasps were
getting “drunk” on fermented fruit and
were going all out in search of more.
Said Joe Mulligan of the Red Cross to the
British newspaper, The Independent, in 2013:
It’s hilarious that, now worker wasps have
finished their life’s work, all they are
doing now is feasting on fermented fruit and
getting ‘drunk’.
All that being said, wasps aren’t just pests,
but benefit humanity in some ways.
They prey on many other “pest” insects
and have actually been used by the agricultural
industry as an effective means to control
crop pests, resulting in a much more environmentally
friendly way to do this over many pesticides.
giant-hornetHornets are actually a species
of wasps.
Hornets differ from other wasps in that their
stings are more venomous (they contain more
acetylcholine); they tend to attack for food
as a colony, and their nests are all aerial
(as opposed to many wasps species).
The Giant Asian Hornet, native to parts of
Russia, China, Vietnam, and the mountains
of Japan, can grow to be about 2 inches long
with about a 4-5 inch wingspan.
It is the world’s largest and most venomous
wasp.
It is colloquially known as the yak-killer,
due to the venom’s ability to dissolve the
tissue of even the largest of mammals.
Because the honey bee is on an individual
level incapable of harming the Giant Asian
Hornet and just a handful of Giant Asian Hornets
are capable of decimating an entire hive of
honeybees, the Japanese Honeybee has come
up with an alternate strategy to stopping
the mass-destruction of their populace by
the hornets.
When the Giant Asian Hornet is detected, first
the honey bee will emit a pheromone that the
Hornet can pick up on that’s basically an
“I see you” warning.
The scouting hornet then may leave in this
case.
ball-hornetIf not, and the hornet continues
towards the hive, the honey bees will ball
the hornet– essentially surrounding it completely
with as many bees as possible.
They will then exert themselves as much as
possible to raise their body temperatures.
Inside the ball, the temperature will rise
rapidly, while simultaneously the carbon dioxide
levels will also increase.
Once the temperature inside the ball passes
115 degrees Fahrenheit or 46 degrees Celsius,
it exceeds what the hornet can tolerate, but
is still well under what the honey bees can
handle (around 50 degrees Celsius).
The combination of heat and low oxygen level
will eventually kill the Giant Asian Hornet.
Several of the honey bees will likely die
before the hornet and this means of defense
isn’t effective against a large number of
Giant Asian Hornets, but it works well at
eliminating the scouting Giant Asian Hornets,
which can potentially stop a large scale attack
from happening in the first place.